hey everybody so this is our real
thoughts on alien versus Predator and
again it was done immediately after we
saw the movie because we just couldn't
shut up about it we're not going to make
this a regular thing we're going to try
not to we're gonna try just keep it kind
of short and tight after we're done
talking about it but sometimes you just
get a-movin you're just you want to talk
about it right away you just have a lot
to say about even if it's something like
alien versus Predator so yeah that's
what this is is this is fresh off
watching the movie I still think we get
some good points across and everything
especially with the emotions being very
fresh and everything so blah blah blah
blah just go let you watch the video god
man yeah that's rough is it i yeah
because it's it's really a very blah man
with a moment da last movie that then
become something good ish like there was
never a moment where I was like oh no
this is great like this is anywhere
close to on par with the original but
like it got goodish and it did it in the
second it's fuckin robed won it wrote
one dit where--how road one starts off
that kind of is you kind of like dull
kind of in them but it ends on such a
higher note I probably actually ended up
liking it a little better than I did
just because the last thing I remember
was the best stuff
well it's unlike Freddy vs. Jason where
it's like it takes forever you're
watching these blank character it's not
that visually interesting and it makes
no sense but you get two fights in this
one it's like they wait till the halfway
point but they spread them out they do
have the fights going on and they do
actually kind of tie in what's going on
with the main game one character and I
like that one a character I like Lance
and there's so nothing going on in the
first half it is film no like it's and
now that I've seen the whole thing is
even worse thinking back is I'm like
don't give a shit about any of the ones
except for the one that makes it I give
it right a hood like I'm glad that I
enjoyed her enough but you didn't need
Lance Henriksen this movie you know you
don't need any of those Ben and ofak
anything I don't know why they make a
Bishop robot a hundred years in
you what it looks like our Guinness
creator like okay so randomly the B
robot we call Bishop and name and that's
what yeah which apparently this is a
cannon anyway so it makes no sense um it
I give a credit that it again it's
trying to be a real movie in the first
half but yet you didn't need it to be a
bandeau right there like the Larry Bird
okay bad how much longer than aim
because we complained I think rightfully
so that Mortal Kombat and event horizon
aren't real movie yeah but this is the
first time like no stop trying to be a
real movie just be like it because all
the real movie stuff in the first half
just is so boring opened a lot sided 85
a nice-lookin has one or two characters
it's nice it's nice looking but I mean
is it but that's not what I want about
an alien vs. predator and it's not that
that's the problem it's not that scary
when it's nice-looking it's too polished
it's too you know when I think of alien
or aliens like there's some nice-looking
stuff
occasion but it's still like got that
gritty kind of things in there like
you're afraid of what's in there yeah
like this needs to be closer to aliens
aliens is not really a pretty-looking
movies actually aliens to me more than a
Lina's claustrophobic like it's really
there's a lot of dark there's a lot of
stroke a lot of people you're a bird
injuries not long shots of these grace
caverns with with all the eggs for the
most part in all of that build-up that
alien head and that's what this needed
to be it just need to be more like
aliens you know I don't care about the
giant shots of the pyramid and and all
of that shit because it's not scary and
he would do these like cuts to like
these shots that are really pretty
looking but I'm like well that just took
the scare out of it there's no
claustrophobia here you gave us a long
wide shot where you can see everything
so I know there's going to be no alien
jumping out right there in the middle of
that scene you're in this movie is
trying to be Gary though I think it's
more trying to be like you know a fight
film okay well that's the case then it
blew it by taking too long to get to get
to it yeah which I agree so but that's a
problem I don't think this film knows
what it wants to be like the first type
it wants to be like alien or what
premedia
Anna being yes definitely no it's a
difference it ends being a different
feel yes and now at the ends being
basically aliens for the most part yeah
and it can't it can't tell what it wants
like I feel like what it was acting more
like aliens it was a way better movie
but that's the problem though James
Cameron still you know we could be what
girl or super groovy but as I'm an
action director he's still one of the
best action directors on the plan and
everything he did he knew how to direct
and choreograph an action scene Anderson
is pieces on us like yeah but you watch
an entire action scene you're like okay
fifty percent of that was kind of fun to
watch and solid and the other 50 percent
he may as well have just been telling
guys flail your arms and I'm going to
shake the camera and I fancy and when it
yeah what'll combat have it wait a half
of that action is good and the other
half is like oh come on you know yeah I
don't know it I have a soft spot for it
I ana's honestly for me I'd say a
fucking table if if it didn't end on a
high note I would rate it much lower but
because if we stole the good stuff was
towards the end so that's the last thing
I'm remembering I'd say it's a C movie
yeah that's kind of my thought see - if
I'm probably being realistic but it to
me it's like kind of a c-minus movie it
got lucky met it ended on fatality yeah
it did do that I would be like this is a
D movie yeah it's one of those movies
for it so even though I thought they'd
totally agree with the criticism there
should be an R and that it should just
be them I don't know one person I have
the same problem in combat but the moral
combat I have a problem with just
because on top of it not being an R
which is the studio song I don't think
it's a very well directed this one at
leave anyone interested in the second
half and fit for the first half I'm
interested I like some of these people
you don't have Johnny Cage falling over
going it's like I legitimately lot of
the mainly none of the
none of the first-half interested me at
all but I didn't actively despise the
character yeah Sonya Blade this was a
legitimately tough Sonya Blade II this
is not a untuck where's Kay no it's like
no this woman can kick my fucking ass to
me the first half of this movie was just
like so getting your oil change in your
car or something or when they're when
you have to wait somewhere so it's like
you're just sitting there waiting you
know it's like a roller coaster it's
like the first half was the hour long
wait for the ride and then the rest was
kind of the ride and when you get off
the ride you're like yeah that was kind
of worth the wait I guess yeah I guess
that was close enough but it's not like
I got off this go down was totally worth
the wait so I kind of in a weird way I'm
kind of happy that getting a little bit
more I love like a fan bases because I
felt like people hated on it so much I
just want they know there was some good
stuff here and some legitimately awesome
stuff that needed credit well I think
the other problem is this is performed
prometheus I think they're like yeah you
know I mean I feel like so much of the
hate was like this is you know this is
homey we had you had an what was it
Alien Resurrection wasn't one before
this yeah was the last one before that
that was like what six years maybe
before the sound of some like that so
you had a six year Wayne yeah people
like I can understand the hate but I
think now since then with where the
series continues to go I think maybe
people will look at this go I know what
this is dumb but at least it has some
like at least it's almost kind of aware
of what it is I like this more than
Prometheus I can almost guarantee I'm
going to like it more than the next one
because it's just going to be promote
Prometheus and alien again and it's are
you gonna be addressing you the next one
I have a note I have no desire at all I
I'm gonna try not to see it unless I
hear like amazing things which is very
unlikely really skies not blowing me
away for years you know
helium-3 was when I don't like alien 3
that much i but i don't actively like
despise it like oh this is the worst
thing ever just complete
like but I'm not gonna lie I mean I like
them more than aliens Horatio like alien
burial as when I was like only that was
that train it all the way through
that's just so boring all the way
through oh and then leaf has some
interesting visitors daily and three
okay I could see here's the problem this
one's more entertaining probably alien 3
I could still take seriously I couldn't
do that with this I don't know it's a
toss-up but if they're very good land
one more trying to be a natural alien
field an alien trees not agreement it's
not a good movie even but it's is aliens
3 to me it's kinda like this like a see
movie that's like the last one to
because like it's your it's alien and
aliens are the only two yeah I'm like no
views were the great movie again since
then it's been a slog of I feel like
alien dream this one me like kind of
like that middle of the road blah like I
didn't take this fucking movie seriously
no back end alien 3 I could take more of
it seriously but I'm just like oh my god
but it wasn't dull yeah and a killing
off the main characters that see that
she really pissed me off like I don't
know after everything that happened to
me I could not follow might know my fit
ya know my favorite thing is about
aliens is I just go and then they
drifted off into space and lived happily
ever after the end
but what about anything there is no
alien drink yeah no it's like but that's
like kind of like the Star Wars prequels
to me it's not only those are the worst
movies but it's like the shit they do
when you compare it to the other ones
it's like a my intro movie 3 what I
liked is they fucking ended it yeah that
was supposed to be it and then they did
Alien Resurrection that was my problem
already with Alien Resurrection I'm like
no yeah I'm like we were done like she
fucking killed yourself at the end of no
we needed to go out on a higher note or
heaven say well you didn't do that she
was just going for full garbage like
this one but does make me laugh though
is like Sigourney Weaver took alien
resurrection because she actually liked
the script it shouldn't like that she
could have a meaty conflicted character
but the funny thing is like I guess she
turned down this one I was reading as
she turned down one of the ones
somewhere just like I don't like the
script I don't she learned her lesson
but oh yeah no I think she was supposed
to be in this like somewhere and I think
she just says pendeks no second comrade
of it as a maybe that's why that was her
exact well like this makes no sense
yeah rather magnet barely made said I
haven't seen the Resident Evil movies
I've never had any desire to know out of
this guy's films I say this was the past
honestly yeah I've never been a fan
tomorrow granted like I said never seen
the Resident Evil have not heard good
things but they made money but her
nothing did not like event horizon
now his original r-rated cut would have
been more interested still and it is we
are another having to get with Magath
this may be I feel like even if it was
like a darker r-rated cut it still would
not have been a great it would have had
a better payoff yeah well maybe would
have been elevated it was still really
honestly I feel like this compared to
vend right into better filmmaking skill
going on it I agree like you know I'm
not the end of the students at Vicky's
are great to read but I'm like if we're
comparing them all like I think this was
crop you know is it not deal Maj is in
this too alien compared to the Oh Maj is
an event horizon event horizon I'm like
fuck dogs shut up every single time I
saw a set ripped off and everything else
here it's like it's a nice little oh ma
yeah a nice little hey we did that but
we're not going to slam it into your
face it's just are like a haze and that
kind of similar thing and it didn't feel
like it was punching you with it we're
event horizon wasn't even an alien movie
I was trying to be an alien movie and
it's fuck damn it
so yeah I don't know I know some people
are just like so despised this the alien
fans and predator fans it was so
hardcore over this but I'm like honestly
I'm suck it's not worth it okay just so
much as oh yeah you can destroy anything
we're into the people I got destroyed
the missile systems like I know a lot of
people I wanted to you know and I can
yeah
anything both I've seen people who love
it I don't love it no I've seen people
who despises me I don't despise it for
me it's not worth it one more now I'm
like yeah this exists like there are
some parts that were mildly entertaining
I'm probably never going to sit through
this film again I would rip you apart
I've seen like if I had seen parts of it
a couple times I would say that it was
an eyeglass - yeah no I would sit
through my go to you go to youtube go
through the clips of it somewhere and
you know even some stuff in the opening
I would look at some of those ah two gay
guys I think they were photographed very
nice and again out of his movies I think
it's the best-looking one but yeah so I
don't know I I don't I don't have any I
don't hate this room I I don't love it
it's just there and if people love it or
hate it that's fine but I that requires
investing like yeah passion and I'm just
like there wasn't much here
no it's merely that I will say this oh
yeah I in this movie's defense no all
right I'll totally give it this out of
all of the sequels post aliens this one
was the least offensive in the sense
that it really did nothing to like wreck
my feeling for the first two movies like
alien 3 is directly connected that kind
of wreck said Alien Resurrection is come
fucking from ETS elegans this one
honestly I'm just like this feels so in
its own other low universe it doesn't
rank the predator movies for me but even
by right under the present ya know even
by having it be 2000 fourth and be like
okay guys to where I don't know it's
like having Q uh what's-her-name
Judi Dench in like Skyfall and Quantum
of Solace and stuff or it's just like
but wait Pierce Brosnan's this is a
prequel but she's in it to me it's like
that dumb shit it's like hers okay it
clearly just kind of it out of all of
them I probably found this to be the
least offensive on that level okay yeah
I mean honestly I'm easy I'm the easiest
with this movie when it comes to how
does it affect the rest of everything
because it feels so separate even from
predator that somebody African threat it
feels close to the predator to me than a
Lia
a month movie yeah it's more of a it's
really more of a predator spin-off than
an alien spin-off to me somebody asked
me on an interview you know what if in
order one of your favorite alien movies
I said okay so probably aliens over yeah
if the aliens alien I thought but I'm
like alien vs. predator because it's
just I would much rather watch this I
much our watches again over in a degree
or row median for entertainment value I
will give you this one yeah over there
yeah I mean I'm seriously I would still
probably go alien three but he only
three ought not a fun movie to sit
through exactly and you're right I mean
this does not be like you're supposed to
take it that seriously and the first
alien is not actually a fun movie to sit
through but it's a much lighter
available yeah aliens is the perfect
combination
it is both scary and amazingly fun to
sit yeah that's why I put it above alien
but no the atmosphere and everything
else in Alien is so amazing I will watch
it all the way through and just people
in a way buy it uh but yes no in terms
of like you know most entertaining it's
just what would I rather put on if I
have all the alien movies what would I
put on aliens sturdy alia middle of the
movie and then you have this one I would
say you know it okay I'll I will go in
on you with that but I would say aliens
alien and then the second half I would
not bother sitting through the first
half and I'm falling asleep I do kind of
feel bad for alien three because I agree
it's legitimately trying to be a real
alien movie and in some respect it
actually does succeed and much more than
this but in terms of what would I rather
put out what would I say like I wanna
actor it and press play yeah I would
want to hiss and they couldn't believe I
said that I'm like really what would you
want to put on what would you want to
put in the DVD player that yes I want to
invest this amount of time in it's like
I could what I really agree with you can
alien Meyer and said you can only watch
one of these again and again and again I
would probably be here there over 83
and with the new one excuse the thing
with the new one the new one would have
to do so but when we're feeling this by
the way new one hasn't come out yet it
would have to do something
extraordinarily impressive or different
with prometheus certainly different like
I feel I just feel like how you know
even if it's done good let's say it's
done good I'm just gonna be saying why
are we still making these why am i
watching this I am keep it on in about I
just don't give a shit about the mythos
I never shoot about the mythos in it not
only humans are building pyramids
because the Predators came down to
convince them they were gods but I still
feel that is overly convoluted for a
warrior Age the warrior race should have
just said like hey let's drop a couple
eggs on this planet and I make a year
yeah and we'll just go hunting like like
I do with all this other shit like Asia
no sense um but then the aliens get over
controls and then they nuked it I'm like
why engine airy tale like I'm gonna get
off the planet like I guess maybe if
some other alien species came and landed
there maybe when to get me compass I'm
wondering if those you know gives at the
very end you see those other predators
show up and there's the ship and
everything a part of me is wondering
were they just there the whole time if
it was like the Warriors tents or
something like that I wonder if that's a
theory at all because that would
actually be really interests and just
the Predators confused me because it's
always supposed like that's where it
might go like people disagree but once
you hate hate on this I go ruins of the
mythos I'm like really that much of a
mezzo speak anyway yeah well not only
that we didn't have fur medias and so we
didn't know where any of this shit was
going and we still don't even would
probably know that's true and even then
with predator I'm just like did it make
any sense to begin with like did you
shit through fucking predator to dude do
you predator to bro why he doesn't like
how mob like predator to just was my
favorite like I didn't seen that movie
since I think high school and I just
remember it's like these great warriors
like you can drop anywhere on the planet
like to hunt and really hunt so why
aren't you dropping into a war zone like
that at least to be made sense about
predator one but part is like we're a
drop in LA I'm like oh I get it it's
like some little arias social commentary
and the button
I'm like come on like it okay in our
world I can drop in Afghanistan or here
the world at that time
la was the moment I get the commentary
but out of the earth la is where you
were going on to Detroit funny which is
the planet Earth and all the battles and
Wars are always going on somewhere honor
I just remember as even when I was
younger hating that I'm ready being
daunced um yeah I may have to put it
because I forget why it was it's like
this isn't some FBI agent of attack
one other thing thing about the first
predator is that I think that redditors
amigo and the interesting thing about
the first part is that is the only
shortened eager movie where
Schwarzenegger is actually topped by
something because he's usually the thing
to see he's the Terminator yeah action
star and that's the predator is the only
thing that actually a legitimately kind
of tops in and people take that out of
the movie more than one to do it
no that's right here and he has the
one-liners and he's being a - eager but
that is the one movie where people take
the editor out and then at 9:00 and it
made sense
I like that acid like it's a warrior
culture going up against you know us
like army Marines and like in the jungle
like I get that so we're going to land
and and to things and stuff like I don't
get why you don't go to jungle war zones
and like search out the people who are
really trained to kill you you want an
awesome fight hmm which was my problem
with this I'm like okay the two guys
with guns are it like the predator has
got to be looking at this like really
like with fucking is like just shooting
minnows in a barrel like they're like oh
this ain't small fish yeah you're
talking about when the Dino morphs come
in I get that you're talking about the
temple the only thing I can figure with
that because you see stuff moving and
booby traps and stuff I'm figuring maybe
that's part of it like a place where
they can hunt and keep on their toes and
stuff but I'm also thinking still what
you said that if they just let them
loose
for Condon Atlantis yeah yeah the jungle
you can still you know have a good honey
you can let them go far and awareness
see that's the problem it's like I don't
get that this is training ground for
them I get that this is like rites of
initiation like the multum attest not
just like oh we're just going to train
like so I know or maybe it was a giant
machine to help control the output of
the alien so there wasn't an over
infestation but starting to see so I
hope it works anyway it is exactly leave
an entire race to get them to do this
for you would you just could have been
pregnant at a few than the boom hmm plus
if they're so badass who cares at the
aliens over infested everything is like
well that's your fucking job and fucking
up them yeah okay I wonder it feels like
they're climbing the ten widening of
it's like these things have shift or
they just come down you pick me up guys
whooping you know that up why are we
teaching the humans to build fucking
temples when they've got all this
space-age technology they could have
just want to build a giant Jurassic Park
fence and put the aliens in there right
none of it me so um but I was kind of
interesting
ya know I like I said I'm glad I finally
got to see us all the way through
because I always saw big chunks of it on
TV it was always playing somewhere and
I'm always like taking it seriously in
stuff Oh see if I know chunks of it and
a lot of them were from the second half
I'd be disappointed if you have to be
like oh man this looks really cool now
fucking sucks no see because I always
heard so many people just say how
terrible and awful it is every time I
saw bits I'm like doesn't see that
barely and I mean like I can see it's
kind of silly and stuff but I mean like
you're not watching all the way through
it's like okay well I see you in the
first half and sorrowful no it's not
good
that's what sees in it it has goodness
it's just that the bargain is that so
weird middle of the road or is like this
is not awful it gets it on the world at
all though I mean like the bar was set
so low and everyone just sits there I
thought
okay I will pay that bar has been set
low yeah kind of amazed that it's as
good as it is yeah so um like I said
it's I got kind of a soft spot for it
even though I totally see the problems
it's hard for me to actually say it's a
good movie but it's like I guess a soft
spot for it I can't help it there is
there's enough legitimately cool stuff
and I'm like okay I'm glad I saw this
I'm not put in a worse mood like with
every other alien movie after aliens
step I will so just honestly I'm in one
of the better moods I've been after
watching it so like consumed with Viva
rock me Rock Stoppers was another
surprise and what I'm not an awful mood
having seen this I'm like it's just more
this exists and I'm kind of same here
I think after Freddy vs. Jason because
they had such a strong reaction from
everybody to use Windows for it I was
kind of like okay maybe it makes sense
to do this too because I've always been
kid because I talked about before and I
said actually I don't dislike this movie
that much and people are always either
like yeah right what's with the hater
like fuck you what the hell's wrong with
you you know kind of things I've always
felt like yeah this would be interesting
to talk about I think there's definitely
we need alien versus Predator versus
gremlins versus Borg
I totally go for a three-way fight with
the grandpa I hear the one after this
Requiem is what everyone thinks the low
bar is going to be for this one I hear
that's pure shit that's where the teens
come in and stuff like that so I yeah
maybe in the future we'll see I don't
know I don't want to need alien versus
Predator versus terminators way it
wasn't their own did they do that no no
there was a terminator and either
predator or aliens uh somewhere there's
a crossover with icing two of the sets I
don't video I don't think all three
would be an amazing clusterfuck yeah is
that like somehow the gremlins get in
there kids it just needs to be like this
epic battle of 80s
success I thought my hofstra doing that
I do feel like though this is part of
the problem it's been just diminishing
returns on this series and when you look
at the director
- you can see why you know Oh God
actually really Scott that's an
interesting one yeah cool feel like
Ridley Scott's never been quite the same
in the past like 15 years
gladiator plucked him up in my opinion
gladdie nothing it's been good since
gladiator gladiator electric matchstick
I think it's a matchstick men that was a
gladiator was overrated when it was out
I didn't get dull I didn't get it either
yeah but I'm like you think of aliens
like James Cameron you know you think a
predator you think was John McTiernan to
their movie and like and we've gone from
that to Paul WS Anderson so no I don't
think he's gonna come nobody here's the
thing there were good you know day
efficient or did a picture of fishin
area button sure but he did three that
the guys right now no no that was part
of the problem you know that was so not
as we like oh no no and that's what's
gonna stay - because the director of
Allah we did ilium resurrect again not
yeah I mean but he's done some creepy
weird movies too but not not alien it's
clearly not alien old-school Ridley
Scott that was his wheelhouse old-school
James Cameron that was his wheelhouse
even I'll make the argument even
new-school James do it really they're
still lavas cliched I need good cuz yeah
um so bit but I don't really go yeah
alien vs. predator Paul WS Anderson no
that wouldn't be my first and which is
why again to be fair you know it would
rise with me how good it was it more as
if if it could be an arm movie I might I
might choose him I might have chosen him
and maybe said look rewrite this a
little bit because there's good elements
in here and stuff and make it an hour
make it better Eisen we want for an
arrival downgrading yet he's not as good
of an action director that's the thing
John but you talking about fucking John
McTiernan and James Cameron that yes
problem if you have to be a good you not
only do have to know how to do suspense
which in a strange way I do feel like
event horizon had better suspense
earlier on in the movie yeah then
film ever did but not only do you have
to do good suspense you have to do good
action and those are two masters of the
genre um and it's just you gotta find
the right person and this could have
been a lot worse
but it still is diminishing returns yeah
I like it better than Freddy vs. Jason
this is just oh I would get a lot more
than that yeah no fuck that Tom Emily
was fuckin light is just waiting forever
to get to the hi Kate I can complain
about things that don't make sense in
this movie what Freddy vs. Jason was
fuckin not like I'm just like is like
you didn't even tell like a computer
wrote this screenplay didn't it like so
literally just it was some random
generator so yeah we'll probably just
make this the real thought Scott out of
my butt then and I've seen better
I've seen worse yeah hey guy it could
have been worse John good a bit our line
of work we know how bad this could be
and I love we go to a lot of people say
Requiem I love I love when people like
come up to me and they're just like how
could you would say that that movie was
even halfway deuces I'm just like or
they'll say things like you know fourth
wake up this garbage and I'm just like
dude Garbage Pail Kids bro I was like
really you do not know garbage just like
we've seen garbage man even like far is
really low if you below the floor right
I honestly bet our buyers one is like
not good but I could totally get through
this even our bar compared to like what
Brad Jones sees and somebody's always
partying our yeah I mean even though you
don't have it alone so yeah guardians of
the galaxy
oh so yeah I think you can get our
initial thoughts on it um yeah you see
see - movie yeah I saw Scott for it I
still enjoy it but I would give that a
rating like I see first half d - second
half B - B maybe so
see I every is out I would say for fee
t- I would say first half C second half
B - I I like that second half I think
it's legitimately cool that man oh yeah
I did a lot behind it it's like a first
half D - and then uh yeah hippy that
girl I can't be that harsh it was
confident but it was boring
I was visually interesting enough and
those couple I heard and written were
interesting enough um Henderson wasn't
interesting at all no I thought it was I
thought when I loved you that an actor
but his can do is don't character there
I'm dying
there it is like yeah we did this so
okay we see we've seen it done worse and
it's like mr. t I thought it's like I
thought he had more passion and emotion
as the fucking robot it is well yes but
still it's good as a human here um so
yeah that gives you an idea and we will
see you next time
you